[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain an american science fiction
action film called aeon flux
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
a deadly virus wiped out 99 of humanity
in 2011 a person named trevor goodchild
finds a cure for the virus and saves one
percent of the human population
the remaining one percent consists of
five million surviving people who now
live in a city called bregna the premise
of the movie is set in the year 2415
404 years after the pandemic
the city of bregna has changed
completely at first glance it looks like
a perfect utopian city with happy people
and a better quality of life
massive concrete walls surround the
circular city to stop people from going
outside the premises and potentially
catching the virus
bregna is technologically advanced and
has a massive spaceship-like object
levitating over the city
for the past 400 years the good child
dynasty has been ruling the city however
the government hides a secret from its
people many people vanish mysteriously
and frequently and no one knows why even
weirder is that the whole population
gets strange nightmares and the
government requests it to be treated
everyone suspects that it is the
government that is involved in the
disappearances but no one is brave
enough to stand against the good childs
except for a group of people called the
monacans monacans are an underground
rebel organization that aims to get the
answers to the frequent disappearance
and fight against the absolute rule of
the good child's
the protagonist of the movie aeon flux
is a highly skilled assassin and a
warrior who works secretly with the
monacans at the beginning of the movie
we see her walking through the streets
of the beautiful city she meets a man at
a junction and the two kiss we see the
man transfer a pill from his mouth to
hers as they kiss
when the two separate and go their own
way aeon takes the pill it is an
advanced telepathic technology used by
the monacans to communicate with each
other by taking the pill aeon is able to
talk to the leader of the monacans named
handler she provides her with a new
mission to sabotage the good child's
central surveillance facility
later we see aeon walk through a busy
street in the city an old man shows
people a picture of his daughter asking
if someone has seen her aeon meets her
younger sister una and the two plan to
meet for dinner that night
after her meeting with una she goes to
the good child's headquarters and very
swiftly kills the three guards outside
she goes further in and defeats the
other guards too they do not match
aeon's fighting and spying skills
she jumps inside through the roof and
sees the life of every person in the
city being watched through some kind of
technology aeon then plants a bug in the
place and completes her mission
successfully
that night aeon is going to una's
apartment but on her way she sees two
men carrying una's body away she is
shocked and freezes in her tracks some
guards bring una's boyfriends behind her
he looks at aeon and tells her that una
wasn't a monacan suggesting that she was
killed for being misunderstood as a
monacan
aeon cannot stop thinking about her
sister at night she pledges to take
revenge on the people who got her killed
a microphone embedded permanently on her
ear tells her that handler wants to see
her she uses telepathic technology to
meet the leader she hands her a new
mission the most important mission they
have had yet it is to kill the man who
has made the cure and chairman of the
good child's rule trevor goodchild aeon
accepts the mission delightedly because
she is getting a chance to kill the
murderer of her sister handler blows her
pollen from a flower and embeds aeon
with the plan of the mission
sethandra aeon's friend and a fellow
member of the monacan will help her
cross the border which is the first step
of the mission
the following day aeon and sethandra
start the plan they run through the
restricted premises of the good child's
residence and are shot by several
weapons planted on the trees sethandra
helps aeon to get through the traps and
leaves her to complete the rest of the
mission alone and waits outside for her
inside the massive residence we see
trevor goodchild talk to his brother and
a co-member of their government oren
goodchild the two talk about a system
their world is working on
trevor is actively trying to better the
said system because it harms the people
currently but oren is in the favor of
continuing the current system even
though it is hurting the people
some time later aeon finds trevor in an
auditorium practicing a speech
she comes in front of him and points her
gun at him however before she can pull
the trigger trevor calls her catherine
aeon gets a flashback of two people
kissing and cannot seem to shoot him
someone from behind her knocks her
unconscious
when she opens her eyes she is in a cell
one of the walls becomes transparent
revealing trevor standing on the other
side aeon asks him about calling her
catherine earlier but trevor doesn't
tell her why he did he claims it is good
to see her again and leaves
a part on the wall reverses offering her
food and water but aeon suspects that
the water is spiked by looking through
her microscope embedded in her eyes she
takes a sample of it with her she then
calls on some marbles that she had
spread throughout the facility the
marbles explode creating an opening
through which aeon runs away
then we see oren and other members of
the government who aren't fond of
trevor's idea talk about aeon's escape
oren dismisses them all but later meets
trevor's secretary inari as they talk we
get to know that oren was the one who
manipulated the monacans into wanting to
kill trevor he wants his brother dead
and wants to do it discreetly so his
death won't track back to him
aeon then goes to see una's boyfriend
who tells her that the liquid she was
given has a message that will be told to
her when she drinks it aeon then drinks
the liquid and trevor talks to her in
her head he asks her why she didn't kill
him earlier when she had a chance and
then he calls her to a place aeon rushes
to go meet him she asks him for an
answer to all this but he instead
questions her why she is here wanting
her to remember the truth herself in the
heat of the moment the two kiss
after a while aeon wakes up naked beside
trevor and is confused she doesn't know
what took over her earlier she strangles
him and knocks him out aeon then finds a
secret door leading to a library an
armor suddenly latches onto her and
brings her to trevor's lab she sees that
he has been performing some kind of
experiment but just then she is
confronted by trevor's personal security
and assistant freya fran knows her as
the assassin sent to kill her boss so
she attacks her the women get into an
intense fight both equally skilled in
the end aeon manages to escape through a
secret opening when trevor comes back to
consciousness freya tells him that she
escaped and he asks her to bring aeon
back alive
oren and the other officials see that
trevor and freya have slept together
they believe that trevor has betrayed
their trust by welcoming a member of the
monacan so they want to dethrone him
altogether
she goes back to meet sethandra and
tells her she has aborted the mission
they get into an argument after which
aeon ties sathandra up and runs away
she sees the floating structure in the
sky through which the good childs keep
an eye on the citizens she climbs up to
reach it inside she sees a strange man
controlling a strange panel the man sees
aeon and welcomes her back
he points towards a direction and
disappears leaving a confused aeon to do
whatever she likes she goes to the panel
and realizes the device has information
about everyone in the city so she
searches for her sister's name as it
turns out una has been reborn as sasha
prelo she gets her address and runs to
see her sister
meanwhile sethandra informs handler
about aeon's betrayal handler assigns
more members of the monacans to
eliminate aeon trevor reaches the flying
object and meets the man who happens to
be the ship's keeper after knowing she
went to see her sister trevor runs there
too
aeon holds her baby sister with teary
eyes when trevor reaches there he
finally reveals to her the truth about
bregna when the virus first spread 400
years ago trevor and a group of
scientists developed the cure and saved
some of the world but the cure had a
terrible side effect it made all the
women infertile so humans only had that
one generation to live however trevor
saved them when his cloning experiment
was successful he cloned the dna of
every person alive and gave them a
rebirth
every person born in the last 400 years
is a clone of the ones who were cured
that is why people have strange dreams
the dreams are the memories of their
past lives
that is also the reason the population
of the place has remained 5 million for
all these centuries
when a person dies in the city the
ship's keeper recycles their dna and
assigns it to someone else
the citizens are unknown to this and
think they have a natural pregnancy but
in reality the keeper of the floating
ship finds a suitable couple to
impregnate and induce the woman with a
chemical pregnancy when they visit the
doctor to see if they are pregnant the
cloned embryo is planted in her that way
she gives birth to a clone of someone
who has recently died
for the past seven generations trevor
and oren have cloned themselves and
taught their younger versions all the
things they need to know
then trevor also tells aeon that this
method is not permanent and he has been
looking for a way to reinduce natural
pregnancy for all these years
turns out uno was subject to trevor's
experiment who had successfully been
pregnant naturally but oren killed her
because he wants the cloning process to
go on forever so he can live forever he
wants to be immortal
as aeon looks at her sister the place is
attacked by oren's men but with aeon's
fighting skills she protects trevor and
the two manage to run away from the
place while being pursued by the men
they reach a train station and escape by
boarding a train however trevor has been
shot
aeon quickly takes him to a nearby quiet
area and takes the bullets out of his
body she peels off her skin and puts it
on his healing his wounds
trevor then claims that they have to go
to his lab to collect his files on the
experiment he performed on una so he
could induce natural pregnancy again
aeon asks him about their relationship
and trevor claims that she was catherine
his wife 400 years ago
oren has told trevor that she died
because of the virus but her dna clone
was protected aeon is beyond surprised
but they do not have much time to chat
when the two reach his lab they see
freya dead and all his reports have been
burned
trevor wants to run away from the city
but aeon insists on doing one last thing
before leaving she wants to destroy the
floating ship because she believes that
cloning is playing with nature humans
are supposed to die and she doesn't want
that to change anymore but before she
can shoot the ship down oren and his men
surround the two at the same time
sethandra and hermonakin's team climb at
a high point to assassinate aeon oren
then reveals to trevor that more and
more women started getting pregnant not
because of trevor's experiment but
because they were healing from the
cure's side effects so he killed them
all including una
that is why the citizens have been
disappearing mysteriously he now plans
to kill both of them and continue the
world of cloning as they talk aeon
notices cythendra far away she uses
telepathy technology to convince her to
help them sethandra and her group begin
to shoot at the guards to save trevor
and aeon during the shootout oren is
injured sethandra's group manages to
kill most of oren's guards however an
injured orrin shoots sethandra and drops
her off the height killing her
in the end trevor and oren come face to
face aeon shoots or undead he points his
gun at trevor aeon then gets on the ship
and explodes it destroying the dna
clones stored inside
the ship goes flying and lands harshly
on the city's perimeter wall the people
see the outside world for the first time
it seems fertile and full of vegetation
a land that can be inhabitable the movie
ends as we see a glance of aeon and
trevor's life 400 years ago
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching